erst der auslandsreise seit corona
bundeskanzlerin merkel spricht dem eu
parlament in brüssel und appelliert an
den zusammenhalt der europäer
aufstand gegen ausgangssperre
demonstranten stürmten das parlament in
belgrad weil die regierung die krone
maßnahmen verschärfen will
und wichtiges urteil für mieter und
vermieter bei schönheitsreparaturen in
unrenovierten wohnungen gilt künftig
kostenteilung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten an meiner seite
ist wenn der sport norbert lehmann ein
beamter von mir
in krisenzeiten ist auch die eu
besonders gefordert und so knüpfen sich
an die deutsche ratspräsidentschaft die
jetzt begann auch besondere erwartungen
vielleicht hat sich bundeskanzlerin
merkel deshalb heute auch nicht auf den
digitalen weg verlassen sondern trug ihr
programm für die nächsten monate lieber
leibhaftig in brüssel vor mit dem wunsch
dass bei den wichtigen themen alle an
einem strang ziehen mögen stefan leifert
es ist die erste auslandsreise der
kanzlerin seit pandemie beginn mit
corona begrüßung und programm für sechs
monate ratspräsidentschaft kommt merkel
nach brüssel und ruft die eu auf sich
nicht spalten zu lassen
wir dürfen nicht naiv sein in vielen
mitgliedstaaten warten die europagegner
nur darauf die krise für ihre zwecke zu
missbrauchen
all jenen müssen wir jetzt zeigen wo der
mehrwert der zusammenarbeit in der
europäischen union liegt merkel wirbt
für solidarität in außergewöhnlicher
krise aber die eu müsse sich auch
komplett erneuern wollen wir europa dann
braucht es das wovon ich heute
gesprochen habe
dann braucht es die grundrechte und den
zusammenhalt dann braucht es antworten
auf den klimawandel und die
digitalisierung dann braucht es europas
verantwortung in der welt da müssen wir
europa grüner digitaler und damit
innovativer und wettbewerbsfähiger
gestalten
doch merkels größte aufgabe die eu
verwaltung über die von ihr
vorgeschlagenen hilfsmilliarden zu
bewahren
die gräben groß die populisten schon in
stellung es ist nicht ihr geld sondern
es ist das geld der dazu nicht befragten
steuerzahler wie diese zeche werden
zahlen müssen es ist statt paternalismus
in intensivster form das alles ist
getrieben im kern von sozialistische
ideologie of the german die deutsche
präsidentschaft das wunder vollbringt
die eu-länder in dieser krise zusammen
zu halten dann wird frau merkel die
gewinnerin sein liebe bringen
im gästebuch des europaparlaments hat
sich merkel schon verewigt
das über ihre ratspräsidentschaft mal in
geschichtsbüchern steht das ist noch
offen
große erwartungen also an die kanzlerin
anne gellinek wie ist sie denn in ihrer
neuen rolle als retterin der eu heute
angekommen in brüssel
naja angela merkel hat die
parlamentarier in brüssel schon umworben
natürlich auch weil sie weiß dass die
das europaparlament am ende dem corona
hilfstopf und dem eu haushalt zustimmen
muss sie hat alle stichworte erwähnt die
man hier gerne hört sie hat von
bürgerrechten und rechtsstaatlichkeit
gesprochen von klimaschutz und
digitalisierung und natürlich auch von
den milliardenschweren hilfsfonds der
als zeichen der solidarität in helfen
soll die länder wider deren wirtschaft
wieder anzukurbeln die vom virus
besonders stark betroffen sind was man
aber auch im europa parlament gehört hat
war sie hat lauter richtige dinge gesagt
aber jetzt muss sie es auch machen und
das beginnt heute hier in brüssel sie
sitzt in diesem moment im
kommissionsgebäude hinter wir mit den
spitzen der eu zusammen und berät
darüber wie ein eu haushalt aussehen
könnte dem alle 27 staats und
regierungschefs zustimmen können
dennoch liegen die positionen sehr weit
auseinander merkel muss ausloten welche
premierminister noch gesondert von ihr
bearbeitet werden muss wer noch welche
nachforderungen hat und dafür hat sie ab
jetzt zehn tage zeit in zehn tagen
beginnt hier der sonder eu gipfel der
staats und regierungschefs wo es genau
um dieses konjunkturprogramm geht ob es
da zu einem beschluss schon kommt das
ist heute abend offen
noch viel zu tun bis dahin vielen dank
an nach brüssel
seit jahren streitet die cdu über eine
frauenquote für spitzenämter
jetzt gibt es einen neuen vorschlag in
der partei darüber entscheiden muss der
parteitag im dezember
demnach soll die quote für
vorstandswahlen ab der kreisebene
schrittweise kommen
anfang 2000 21 ist ein frauenanteil von
30 prozent vorgesehen ab 2023 sind 14 40
prozent festgelegt ab 2025 gilt demnach
eine quote von 50 prozent
florian hat die details
die union hat einen frauenproblem das zu
erkennen dafür reicht ein blick in den
bundestag 80 prozent der fraktion männer
das soll sich ändern nach elf stunden
verhandlungen präsentiert die struktur
und satzungskommission der cdu in der
nacht diesen vorschlag eine verbindliche
quote ab 2025 müsste demnach die hälfte
aller ämter mit frauen besetzt werden
noch auf dem parteitag im dezember hatte
die frauen union an den solchen antrag
mangels erfolgsaussicht zurückgezogen
gibt sich nun erfreut es ist kein
selbstzweck es geht um die
zukunftsfähigkeit alle männer und frauen
in der cdu haben etwas davon wenn die
volkspartei starkes wenn sie attraktives
in allen bevölkerungsgruppen nur ein
viertel der cdu mitglieder sind frauen
zu wenige so wendet sich selbst manche
cdu politikerin gegen eine feste quote
am ende dazu führt dass posten unbesetzt
bleiben und männer die wollen die können
die die gut sind für uns die können im
zweifel dann diesen posten nicht
übernehmen und das ist doch ungerecht
im vergangenen oktober scheiterte die
csu-führung mit ihrem vorhaben einer
verbindlichen quote
eine erfahrung die cdu politiker ebenso
harte debatten erwarten lässt beim
parteitag in stuttgart im dezember
entscheidend dürfte dabei auch sein wie
sich der künftige parteichef
positioniert weder armin laschet noch
friedrich merz aber wollten den
vorschlag heute kommentieren
lediglich der ebenfalls kandidierende
norbert röttgen ließ seine unterstützung
erkennen in der politik kann die quote
helfen grüne und linke machen es seit
jahren vor
schwieriger wird es im ganz normalen
leben die korona krise hat es gerade
wieder gezeigt immer wenn es eng wird
bleibt die arbeit in der familie und bei
der pflege also oft allein an den frauen
hängen
das und andere benachteiligungen will
die bundesregierung jetzt angehen mit
einer großen nationalen gleichstellungs
strategie bgh stellt sie vor
franziska gefräst unter anderem
ministerin für frauen und ab heute sind
ihre kollegen und kolleginnen das
irgendwie
bei allen gesetzen und programmen will
die regierung künftig für
chancengleichheit von frauen und männern
sorgen nennt das nationale
gleichstellungs strategie es ist ganz
ganz wichtig dass diese themen mal
strukturiert zusammengepackt werden und
das ist auch eine gemeinsame
verständigung gibt die strategie an sich
dieser entschluss alle ressorts dafür
zur arbeit nicht zu sagen dafür haben
wir doch im gleichstellungsministerin
macht das frauenministerium er gab ihr
auch noch schlimmere sprüche dazu zu
diesem thema sondern diese diese dieses
bekenntnis zum allerersten mal
das hat jahrzehnte gedauert die
bundesregierung will folgende probleme
angehen für gleiche arbeit gleiche
bezahlung renten unterschiede
ausgleichen die immer noch bis zu 50
prozent betragen
klassische frauenberufe aufwerten auch
durch mehr geld keine erziehung und
arbeit im haushalt gerechter aufteilen
und mehr frauen in die parlamente
wissenschaft und den öffentlichen dienst
bringen
es ist wichtig wie gesagt dieses thema
auf die tagesordnung zu holen
umso enttäuschter war ich allerdings als
ich dann gesehen habe das ministerium
gipfel und das gesamte kabinett im
prinzip nur altbekannte forderungen
aneinandergereiht hat also wirklich viel
innovatives ist nicht dabei gewesen
wie ernst es der koalition ist kann sie
nun beweisen um ein schärferes gesetz
für mehr frauen in führungspositionen
streitet sie seit längerem rhetorik ist
das eine taten das andere
corona kann gesellschaftliche konflikte
gefährlich verschärfen in serbien etwa
in belgrad gab es gewaltsame proteste
gegen angekündigte neue ausgangs
beschränkungen und gegen den präsidenten
alexander witsch der vorwurf er habe die
schutzmaßnahmen gegen das virus vor
einigen wochen überstürzt gelockert nur
um wahlen zu einem für ihn günstigen
zeitpunkt abhalten zu können kommt
kletterten die infektionszahlen danach
in die höhe
britta hilpert berichtet die gewalt der
letzten nacht hat in belgrad spuren
hinterlassen nicht nur solche die man
aufholen
gespalten die meinung zu den protesten
gestern ausgelöst durch die ankündigung
eines neuerlichen lockt das promi der
protest war nicht gerechtfertigt meint
er
er war gewalttätig heute abend werden
wir wieder protestieren wir müssen
einfach alles rund um corona ist nur
lüge lüge lüge
tausende protestierten gestern gegen das
corona management der regierung
das habe die zweite infektionswelle erst
befördert meinen viele
als sie das parlament stürmen eskaliert
die gewalt
nach offiziellen angaben werden 17
demonstranten verletzt aber 43
polizisten politische schönfärberei
verdeckte mängel und gesundheitssystem
auch deshalb entlädt sich zorn diese
papa und dieser protest ist für dich du
bist gestorben war es nicht genügend
atemgeräte gibt nicht liebe die segnung
norbert gewonnen
sie bauen not kliniken 300 neue
infizierte pro tag das gesundheitssystem
ist am limit
experten sagen der politisch motivierte
wechsel von lok down und lockerungen
beförderte die pandemie den zorn darüber
kann sich präsident vucic heute nur so
erklären niveau es waren da nicht nur
kriminelle sondern auch ausländische
geheimdienste am werk sagt er
und auch dass es ziel sei serbien zu
destabilisieren oder industrie mix
roseby belgrad vor einer stunde
sie werden heute wieder demonstrieren
obwohl die regierung nun ankündigte den
lock down zu überdenken
corona schaukel kurs der beruhigen soll
aber wohl kaum beruhigen
die usa haben ihre drohungen wahr
gemacht und nun offiziell den austritt
aus der weltgesundheitsorganisation
eingeleitet wirksam wird er dann in
einem jahr präsident trump hatte der whu
in der korona krise immer wieder
vorgeworfen zu china freundlich zu sein
gleichzeitig infizieren sich in den usa
täglich so viele menschen neu mit dem
virus wie nie zuvor
mehr als 60.000 warnes gäste insgesamt
zählt das land inzwischen mehr als 3
millionen fälle zur aktuellen lage in
deutschland da bleibt die zahl der
registrierten neuinfektionen stabil
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 420 menschen täglich neu mit
dem virus angesteckt gestern lag diese
zahl bei 430 mit viel geld will die
bundesregierung der wirtschaft durch die
krise helfen
in einem neuen schritt speziell kleinen
betrieben und mittelständlern die durch
bewohner in not geraten sind und jetzt
um ihre existenz bangen
ihnen sollen jetzt überbrückungshilfen
gewährt werden in höhe von insgesamt 25
milliarden euro zuschüsse die nicht
zurückgezahlt werden müssen das programm
richtet sich an firmen deren umsatz im
april und mai im vergleich zum vorjahr
um mindestens 60 prozent zurückgegangen
ist die details bühne ton licht gefeiert
und inszeniert wird immer wähnt man sich
in der veranstaltungsbranche hier in
mainz auf der sicheren seite
dann kommt corona und von 1200 events im
jahr bleiben noch ein paar
pressekonferenzen 30 jobs stehen auf der
kippe
aber nach der korona soforthilfe winkt
jetzt der zweite scheck aus berlin wenn
es die hilfe nicht gäbe hätten wir
wahrscheinlich schon zum ende juni
insolvenz angemeldet oder das
unternehmen noch weiter reduziert
mitarbeiter gekündigt und geguckt dass
man vielleicht das ein oder andere
verkauft mit dem man aber wenn es
irgendwann mal wieder losgeht ja geld
verdienen will am mittag auftritt
wirtschaftsminister altmaier seine
botschaft der staat überbrückt und hilft
aus der korona patsche unbürokratisch
online
der zuschuss muss nicht zurückgezahlt
werden das ist ganz wichtig damit die
unternehmen durch die bewältigung der
fixen größe
nicht wichtige teile ihres eigenkapitals
verzehren und die maximale förderung
beträgt 150000 euro für drei monate geld
vom staat das hätte auch etm in saalburg
thüringen gerne bekommt aber nichts
zwar sind auch hier die umsätze
weggebrochen doch das reicht nicht denn
bevor corona zuschlug hatte der
autozulieferer einen umbau gestartet
eine phase schlechter bilanzzahlen
gefördert werden aber nur firmen denen
es vor der pandemie gut ging der
altmaier plan greife zu kurz so die
opposition
insgesamt sehen wir die große sorge dass
im herbst eine insolvenzwelle auf uns
zurollt hierauf hat die bundesregierung
unter bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier
bisher keine antwort die
überbrückungshilfe nicht alle bekommen
sie und nicht allen wird sie reichen
staat und wirtschaft fahren in corona
zeit weiter aussicht die korona krise
hat es ans licht gebracht die
unterbringung von bergs arbeitern in der
fleischindustrie ist oft katastrophal
die menge reichen von schimmelpilz und
ungeziefer befall bis hin zur
einsturzgefahr bestätigte jetzt eine
untersuchung des landes nrw die
schlechte unterbringung der arbeiter wie
hier in gütersloh gilt als mitursache
für die korona ausbrüche in
fleischfabriken bei der untersuchung von
650 solcher wohnungen im mai wurden fast
1900 mängel dokumentiert das motiv hass
auf die familie von weizsäcker für den
mord am jüngsten sohn des ehemaligen
bundespräsidenten ist heute ein
57-jähriger mann verurteilt worden er
muss zwölf jahre in haft und wird in
einer psychiatrie untergebracht
der mann habe vor acht monaten den arzt
fritz von weizsäcker bei einem vortrag
heimtückisch und aus niederen
beweggründen erstochen so das
landgericht berlin
weil der täter psychisch gestört ist ist
er nur vermindert schuldfähig
wenn der maler kommt wände und decken
streicht kann das ganz schön teuer
werden kein wunder dass die sogenannten
schönheitsreparaturen immer wieder zu
streit zwischen vermietern und mietern
führen was zb
wenn der mieter die wohnung renoviert
übernimmt jahre später aber doch
verschönerungen einfordert dazu hat der
bundesgerichtshof heute ein
salomonisches urteil gefällt
birgit franke mit den details christian
emmerich wohnt seit 2002 in seiner
berliner mietwohnung die ehrung
renoviert übernommen hat nach 14 jahren
verlangt er von der vermieterin dass
diese die wohnung tapeziert und streicht
die sogenannten schönheitsreparaturen
übernimmt kostenpunkt 7300 euro
doch die vermieterin weigert sich
emmerich klagt ich habe geklagt weil ich
der meinung war dass die
schönheitsoperation klausel die in
unserem mietvertrag enthalten ist
unwirksam ist sondern dass das viel mehr
beim vermieter grundsätzlich geht schon
bei den wirten wohnungen sind einige
schönheitsreparaturklauseln im
mietvertrag unwirksam zum beispiel
starre instandhaltungs fristen eine
endrenovierungsklausel die pflicht an
den handwerker zu bestellen bei
unrenovierten wohnungen gelten die
schönheitsreparaturklausel fazit der
mieter muss nicht mal an so wie im fall
emmerich doch muss dann automatisch der
vermieter bei einer deutlich ab
genutzten wohnung die arbeiten
übernehmen der bgh sagt heute ja aber
der mieter muss sich an den kosten
hälftig beteiligen grund der mieter
hatte nur eine unrenovierten wohnung
gemietet wenn nun schönheitsreparaturen
durch den vermieter durchgeführt werden
dann erhält er ja mehr als er eigentlich
angemietet hat und daher ist es gerecht
wenn er sich zur hälfte an den
renovierungskosten beteiligt der
deutsche mieterbund rät jetzt mieter
sollten mit dem vermieter reden um
streit über die kosten zu vermeiden
und nun zum sport und zur norbert und
zur fußball bundesliga relegation gönner
und da hat zweitligisten nürnberg
gestern abend einen großen schritt in
richtung klassenerhalt gemacht
durch den 2 0 hinspielsieg gegen den
dritten der dritten liga den fc
ingolstadt und zu verdanken haben die
nürnberger das einem herrn nürnberger
fabian nürnberger heißt der mann der mit
seinen ersten beiden profi toren den
sieg perfekt machte heute finde ich
unheimlich gute fähigkeiten im abschluss
linke fuß lange ecke das demonstriert
der mittelfeldspieler in der 22 minute 1
zu 0 kurz vor der pause trifft
nürnbergern nochmal für den klar
überlegenen zweitligisten 2 zu 0 und nur
der pfosten verhinderte ein drittes tor
das trübt seine überragende leistung
aber nicht
ich musste ja das dritte denkt noch mal
angucken ich glaube mich hat er gesagt
ich kann mir überlegen das bisschen
ärgerlich aber ansonsten ja glücklich
über die ersten zwei tore
drittligist ingolstadt ist überfordert
nur drei höchstens ansatzweise
gefährliche abschlüsse in der ganzen
partie
nun heißt es hoffen auf ein
fußball-wunder im rückspiel
wir sehen uns jetzt erst einmal
schütteln und man konnte gerade in der
zweiten halbzeit sehen wenn wir mutiger
sehen und selbstbewusst agieren dass wir
dann doch eine chance haben wenn aber
fabian nürnberger ähnlich spielt wie
gestern dürfte für die nürnberger kaum
noch etwas schiefgehen bei der mission
klassenerhalt und das
relegationsrückspiel zwischen ingolstadt
und nürnberg bei uns zu sehen am samstag
live im zdf ab 18 uhr
überraschendes comeback in der formel 1
19 monate nach seinem ausstieg aus der
königsklasse des motorsports hat
fernando alonso nächste saison wieder
beim renault-rennstall an 2018 abu dhabi
der rücktritt des spanischen all stars
verabschiedet von seinen fahrerkollegen
mit entsprechender choreografie die
großen zeiten des 38-jährigen die liegen
schon weit zurück 2005 und 2006 holte er
seine beiden einzigen weltmeistertitel
damals noch in packenden duellen mit
michael schumacher
das war so lange karriere ja danke
norbert und wir haben noch die
lottozahlen für sie die gewinnzahlen
lauten 9 15 23 8
und 20 41 44 und die superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 57
zum wetter da wird's im süden heiß und
sonnig im norden eher nass und kühl zu
den einzelheiten gleich mehr von gunther
tiersch so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 10 14
zum heute-journal und wir sind morgen
wieder für sie da punkt 19 uhr
machen sie sich noch einen gemütlichen
abend tschüss
[Musik]
einige zuschauer zwei regentage liegen
noch vor uns auch in rostock morgen an
der ostsee wird es wohl nass werden im
tagesverlauf
es sind so kleine wellen die immer
wieder vom atlantik zu uns ziehen und
mitteleuropa überqueren die nächste
welle das nächste wolkenband wird ein
bisschen weiter nach norden ziehen und
das bedeutet die wärme aus dem süden die
karten wieder die mitte deutschlands
erreichen
heute nacht also haben wir erst mal den
regen weiterhin vom münsterland bis zum
bayerischen wald dazu wird es im
norddeutschland richtig frisch
schleswig-holstein sieben grad sonst zum
teil bis 12 im süden 13 bis 16 grad auch
im westen ist es sehr mild morgen dann
eben auch in der mitte wieder 23 grad
zum teil im süden sogar 27 bis 32 grad
es wird heiß werden im norden bleibt es
eben immer noch frisch 16 bis 19 grad
und im norden liegt der meiste regen
niedersachsen sachsen anhalt das zieht
sich bis zu den küsten da wird auch mal
regnet und wir haben dort einen frischen
ostwind sonst einen frischen west bis
südwestwind südlich des mains ist es
dann trocken und da scheint dann auch
immer wieder die sonne vor allen dingen
südlich der donau
ja die aussichten haben freitag kommt
der wetterwechsel mit schauern und
gewittern von nordwesten kühler und am
wochenende wird es dann schon wieder
freundlicher werden
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut